Good afternoon.
I hope everyone is enjoying this extraordinary annual meeting here in San Diego.
I'm Dr. David Kirsch, a senior scientist at University Health Network's Princess
Margaret Cancer Centre.
It is my privilege to serve as chair of this year's selection committee for
the AACR Award for the Lifetime Achievement in Cancer Research.
The AACR established this prestigious award in
2004 to honor individuals who have made significant
and fundamental contributions in cancer research, who've had a
lasting impact on the field, and have demonstrated a lifetime commitment to
progress against cancer. This year's honoree is a scientist whose
work has fundamentally transformed cancer research and profoundly
impacted our field and cancer patients we serve.
The 2026 AACR Award for Lifetime Achievement in Cancer
Research is being awarded to Dr. James P.
Allison of the University of Texas MD Anderson Cancer Center.
Dr. Allison's discovery and development of immune checkpoint blockade
therapy revolutionized cancer immunotherapy and reshaped
the clinical landscape across many cancer types.
Early in his career, Dr. Allison focused on understanding the fundamental
biology of T cell activation and regulation.
His laboratory identified key components of the T cell response,
including the T cell receptor, which recognizes antigens presented
by MHC molecules, and CD28, a critical
co-stimulatory receptor required for full T cell
activation. In the mid-1990s, Dr.
Allison made a landmark discovery by demonstrating that CTLA-4
functions as a negative regulator of T cell activation, a
brake on the immune response.
At a time when most efforts in immunotherapy focused on
stimulating the immune system, Dr.
Allison proposed a bold and unconventional idea that blocking
inhibitory pathways could unleash antitumor immunity.
His laboratory tested this hypothesis in preclinical models,
showing that inhibition of CTLA-4 led to complete tumor
rejection. This work laid the foundation for a new therapeutic
paradigm, immune checkpoint blockade, a term coined by Dr. Allison.
Translating this concept into the clinic required extraordinary
persistence and vision, particularly in the face of skepticism and
prior failures in immunotherapy.
Ultimately, this work led to the development of the anti-CTLA-4
antibody ipilimumab, which in 2011 became the first immune
checkpoint inhibitor approved by the FDA after demonstrating a
survival benefit in patients with metastatic melanoma.
Notably, a subset of these patients experienced long-term, durable
remissions lasting more than a decade. Dr.
Allison's discovery catalyzed the development of an entirely new class
of cancer therapies, including inhibitors targeting
PD-1, PD-L1 pathway. Today, immune checkpoint blockade
therapies are approved across numerous cancer types and have provided
lasting benefit with improved survival to hundreds of thousands of patients
worldwide. Importantly, Dr. Allison's work established a new principle in
oncology that targeting the immune system, rather than the tumor alone, can
produce durable and potentially curative responses.
This paradigm shift continues to guide the development of next-generation
immunotherapies and combination strategies. Dr.
Allison remains at the forefront of cancer research, leading efforts to understand
mechanisms of response and resistance to immunotherapy and to expand
its benefits to more patients. He currently leads the James P.
Allison Institute at the University of Texas MD Anderson
Cancer Center. Among his many honorees, Dr.
Allison was awarded the Nobel Prize in Physiology or Medicine in 2018
for his groundbreaking discoveries in cancer immunotherapy. The impact of Dr.
Allison's work is profound. His insights into immune
regulation and his relentless commitment to translating discovery into therapy
have saved and extended countless lives and continue to shape the future of
cancer treatment. It's my great honor to introduce the 2026
recipient of the AACR Award for Lifetime Achievement in Cancer Research,
Dr. James Allison.
Thank you, Dr. Kirsch, for that wonderful introduction.
I'm glad to find all you guys, actually.
I was sitting in a smaller room for a little while thinking this was it, and there
was almost nobody in there. And I thought, "Well, at least my friends ought to
come." But I discovered I was sitting in 6D or something then.
Anyway, I'm here and glad to see all of you.
And today, I would like to just talk a little bit about
the background of checkpoint blockade, but more about some recent
work that we've been doing, about some details of the mechanism,
that are kind of interesting. I'm not going to give you too much
up-to-date stuff on the clinical things.
Just in the time permitted, I can just talk about the
new mechanistic stuff that we got.
Anyway, here are my disclosures. Don't invest in many of
these companies. Most of them are underwater now anyway, because everything's
down. I say that because one time somebody photographed my
disclosure slide and published it in a magazine saying, "This is what
you all are..." Anyway, don't do that.
Anyway. Well, why immunotherapy?
Well, this is an old slide, but I'll show it again because it sort of
started these things off, and that's because of what cancer is.
Cancer is a disease with lots of mutations, as we all know.
And it's many different diseases if you look at it that way, each of which is
caused by a different driver, and that's how you design therapies.
But what people have found in the last years is that targeting single mutations
doesn't work, partially because there's always another driver in the population,
and that one will just take over when you kill all the first ones.
So,
it's hard to see how that's going to be really curative.
It's been calculated there are 14 different ways a melanoma cell
can escape
the perfect BRAF
inhibitor.By using other pathways, et cetera.
So it's kind of hard to think how you could put 14 different things together in a
therapy. Any event, immunotherapy's been disregarded for a
long time because it had a lot of problems working, but theoretically it
ought to work. One is specificity.
What we know now, and suspected for a long time, is the target
of T cells in immune response isn't to the tumor
antigens you've read about in the class book, in the textbook so much as it is
those that are produced by these mutations.
And not just the drivers that the tumor biologists are interested in, but
also the passengers of our immune system can see those as well.
Anything that changes an amino acid that's expressed
and fits the MHC of the patient can be an antigen, whether it's a
driver or not. The immune system doesn't care.
And once you've got T cells that could see it, they give rise to memory cells,
of course, so potentially you've got those cells for the rest of your life that
could come back. And if the tumor changes, you can easily just poke around
with it again and get the immune system, which is a living thing itself, to
adapt to that and change to it. So that's just another way of saying it's
been clear for a long time that the immune system's a match for cancer,
but
let's just go ahead and try. So I thought it'd be a good idea to figure out really
in detail how T cells work when I started all this.
So we know now that there's signal one, which is the T cell antigen receptor.
That's not enough. You need another costimulatory signal, which is
CD28. Only when a T cell gets all that signal
does it really turn on and start to divide
by turning on these cell cycle things and making growth factors and then
proliferate. Because you've got to grow that minority of cells into an army
to kill the tumors. So that's the key expansion phase that has to
occur very fast to get rid of tumors.
But CTLA-4 comes along. It's turned on when you turn on CTLA-4,
and after a while, CTLA-4 accumulates, and we think it gets
to a point it's got about a three-log advantage over CD28
in binding the ligand. So it outcompetes CD28.
It turns off costimulation, and the cells gradually
come to a stop. And so the idea I had was that, well, maybe the tumor
cells are really, they're
antigenic, but maybe they
can't give the costimulatory signal.
And sure enough, we showed that was the case, and they can't behave like an
antigen-presenting cell as you see here.
This is a T cell with CD28. You can see it fusing in the
membrane. It's a GFP fusion as the T cell contacts the,
in this case, antigen-presenting cell.
But after that, the CTLA-4 comes around.
It's in vesicles at the back of the cell, and it's drug then to the
synapse, and actually, the molecules seem to be sprayed into the synapse.
And there they could form because it's a
multimeric
binding of B7-1, which is also multimeric.
You get a really high avidity thing, which just pushes CD28
out of the synapse. So that's how it works.
But anyway, the way it works in cancer is that tumor cells can't give
those second signals, at least most solid tumors.
At least no solid tumor can because they don't have the B7
molecule. We showed that when the B7 was identified as
the common ligand for both CD28 and CTLA-4.
We put B7 into a number of tumors, and they won't even grow in mice because
they elicit an immediate immune response, whether they were considered really
poorly immunogenic or highly immunogenic.
So the problem isn't they lack antigens.
The problem is they can't initiate an immune response.
So the idea that gave rise to checkpoints blockade is that the tumor gets a
head start. You try to generate T cells, but CTLA-4 turns them
off before you can get enough. So all we need to do is turn
CTLA-4 off, and we can get tumors to
grow. So this is one of the lot of experiments we did to
prove that this is the case.
Dana Leach and Max Krummel specifically did this experiment
showing that if you inject a mouse with a tumor and it grows, if you inject
an antibody to CD28 and block it, the tumor grows faster,
showing there is a nascent immune response there, but it just can't get
it done. But if you inject anti-CTLA-4, those tumors
grow for a while and then get rejected. And those mice are permanently immune.
The mice will never take that tumor again.
We've tried that with many different tumor lines of mice, and it
always worked, either by itself or with a vaccine or a little bit of
chemo or something. But this was really a powerful way of allowing T
cells to
attack cancer. So with a lot of
help from friends and others, we made the ipilimumab
antibody, initially called MDX-010.
And even it went in about
2000 or so. It went into clinical trials first.
It's
early trials in other kinds of cancer, but finally focused in melanoma.
And in the Phase I in melanoma, there were, I think, 3 out of 14 patients
that had CRs. So it really got everybody's attention and
led to the Phase III trial.
Sharon Belvin here was one of the early
participants in the Phase III trial that Jedd Wolchok ran at Sloan
Kettering. She was diagnosed in
2015. '14 and '15.
She was being treated for
metastatic melanoma. It had completely
gotten in her lungs. She couldn't breathe well. That was how she presented.
She had 31 mets in her lungs, as you can see here.
Her liver was also completely riddled with too many to count,
and she had a centimeter-and-a-half brain tumor, as it turned out.
She had two rounds of chemotherapy, a round of radiation to no effect,
and then Jedd told her she had the choice of hospice or
CTLA-4. She got a treatment with CTLA-4.
Within a few months, her tumors were just completely gone.
When she came back for a checkup,
there was a lot of confusion because they couldn't find any sign that she had
cancer on any of her films, on any of the diagnostic stuff.
And so the radiologist at first thought that they'd been mixed up or something, but
it turned out it hadn't. Anyway, so she went on to a CR.
There are her two kids in 2016, and I saw herThis
summer early, and those two kids are about ready to go to college.
Everybody's still fine, and she's had no reason for relapse, no reason for
any treatments or anything in 21 years now since she got
it. So she's one of the most-- There were earlier survivals from some of the
other smaller trials, but the earliest from that phase from that
trial that Jed did. Anyway, when the trial finished, there were about 20% of
the patients that were alive, and that was extended for 10
years. About 20% of patients with melanoma
were alive
10 years after treatment with ipilimumab, which is pretty
significant considering that when we started this trial, the
median survival was seven months, six to
seven months for melanoma. And virtually, no one lives past five years.
But 20% lived past 10 just with a single agent trial with
CTLA-4.
But of course, what about the other 80%? Why didn't they respond?
Well, I could give you some mechanistic
interpretations, but the other explanations-- But the other possibility was there
are other checkpoints. And sure enough, just about the time these results were
coming in, Tasuku Hanjo, with the help of Gordon Freeman and
Arlene Sharpe, showed that PD-1 was another checkpoint. But it's very different.
It's expressed on exhausted cells, as I think everybody knows now,
and gives rise to these precursor cells, the CD8s.
So it acts on cells that have already been through differentiation and
totally know their function. I'm bringing this up because it makes a
big difference, as I'll show you in a moment, as to what they do and how they
act against tumors. But in any event, PD-1 went in trials.
It also worked like CTLA-4 blockade did against a lot of different kinds of
cancer, gave durable responses. This is putting the two together, which
made sense. This was a trial, again, that Jed led.
This shows the ipi single arm, the nivo single arm.
This is the 10-year follow-up that was published a couple of years ago.
And you can see now the survival of patients is over
50%
after that treatment. Basically, after three years, nobody died of
melanoma that was treated on this trial.
And actually, there are some people now, as I showed you, that are out 20 years.
So after about three years, you don't even have to worry too much about checking
the patients because they're probably good to go after that point.
So this is quite an event in melanoma, just being able to go from an
incurable disease to curing more than half of it.
But I will tell you, with the advent of neoadjuvant
trials initiated initially by Pam Sharma on bladder cancer, even
before CTLA-4 was approved, neoadjuvant trials have been
going at MD Anderson, have had
response rates of over three-year and four-year survival of over
70% now. So if those small trials prove to be
durable, we're going up and getting the response rates up
even higher by just
throwing more stuff at them mechanistically.
Anyway, this slide, as everybody knows, to 80 to a lot, just a whole,
starting in 2011 with the approval of ipi.
Pembro, the PD-1 antibody, the year after, the combination of ipi and
nivo also. 2014, the combination was approved.
And since then, a raft of approvals of various combinations,
mostly with PD-1,
different PD-1s from different companies in a whole variety of tumors.
I'm not going to go through all those. That's for a different time.
But just to summarize it, there are over 80 approvals now.
Millions of people have been treated with checkpoint blockades.
I didn't even touch anything yet.
I don't know what's going on. Anyway, now it's moved to frontline
therapy in melanoma and some other cancers.
And fully 45% of patients with newly diagnosed
cancers that just show up would be eligible for treatment
with
checkpoint agents at the current approval status, and that's going up
daily as we see. It's been estimated over a million
Americans have had durable remissions now since
2011.
That's remissions of over five years, so
quite a bit of bang for that. But we still need to know the mechanisms if we're
going to make this work better for more patients.
So I want to just go through and give you a comparison
of some of the mechanistic properties of blocking CTLA-4
and blocking PD-1 because they're quite different and quite
complementary, which is why they work so well.
As I said, CTLA-4 is hardwired. It's built in for every immune response,
and it's there to stop your immune system after it's taken
care of whatever the agent is and not kill you, the T cells not being
able to stop dividing because if you knock CTLA-4 out in mice,
they die when they're about three weeks old because they fill up with T cells
because that is the main mechanism for stopping their
proliferation. It targets, as I said, the
CD28 pathway. Works during priming, and that has a bunch of
implications. The first one is we've shown back in the
mid-'90s
that it lowers
the threshold that you need for the avidity of the peptide MHC
complex to activate a TCR and get it over the threshold
for activation. It lowers that threshold, so it brings new
clones into response. This has been shown both in patients and in mice.
PD-1 doesn't do that. It just expands the clones that were there
before.
CTLA-4, as I'll show you, as a monotherapy preferentially will give you
CD4 cells, but for a reason that's kind of surprising, and I will show
you. Whereas PD-1 as a monotherapy only
affects CD8s. But when you combine them, it works on
CD4s as well. CTLA-4 can move T cells into cold
tumors, at least prostate and bladder that
Pam Sharma showed. But PD-1, right alongside
CTLA-4, does not move T cells into those tumors when they're
cold. Adverse events with CTLA-4 are more frequent than they
are with PD-1. They're essentially the same kinds, but a lot more frequent.Which is
one of the reasons it's used a lot less frequently.
On the other hand, disease recurrence after treatment with CTLA-4 is really
rare, but after PD-1, it's quite frequent.
In melanoma and lung cancer, about
25% to 35% at two years or so, or like
I said, in combinations and after three years, it settles down.
The reasons for this, we published a couple of years
ago, and I'm not going into it again.
It's because the cells that are expanded by CD8, and I'll show you a number
of this in a moment,
still have TCF7, which is the stem cell factor
that the people that worked on the CD8 differentiation,
John and his friends talk about, whereas PD-1 expands only the
tox-positive effector cells, again, effective difference in
working during priming and after terminal exhaustion because the PD-1 doesn't even
work until the cells are fully functional, and then the
cells have lost their stem cell capacity and can't proliferate.
CTLA-4 because of the enormous amounts of cytokines that are
produced, can remodel myeloid cell populations, and I'll show you that in a
moment. Whereas PD-1 doesn't seem to do that
extensively without help. And so one of the first things we did, we
meaning Spencer Wey, a postdoc in the lab,
was when CyTOF came out, is to use that. I'm not going to go through it.
It's just high-dimensional cell sorting.
But we did this looking at different T cell types, keeping
track of individual mouse sizes, so we could relate
changes to individual mice. And we started off using the
MC38. This is a high mutational load
colorectal carcinoma, if you will, of mice.
But we got the same results with a very poorly immunogenic melanoma,
the B16 melanoma, where we had to use a vaccine along with it,
and we got basically, the same results with
both, whether highly immunogenic or a combination therapy.
And first, I'm going to show you just the CD4 and CD8 cell data.
So the CD8 data shown in the upper left,
these are the exhausted CD8s. When you treat, these are the cells we'd have.
If you looked at it by flow, they'd have
PD-1, LAG-3, and TIM-3, all three of them, and they
would have exhausted epigenetic markers as well.
But as you can see, those are not expanded by CTLA-4 monotherapy.
They are expanded by PD-1, but when you give
CTLA-4 with the combo, they go
down. They go way down below control values.
Not only do they go down, but the Spearman's coefficient is shown all in the
right, showing that in untreated or in PD-1-treated
mice,
the number of those cells, the triple positively
exhausted, terminally exhausted CD8s, is
linearly correlated with small tumors.
The more of them, the smaller the tumor is.
But if you add CTLA-4, not only are they not there anymore, but they also
don't correlate at all with tumor outcomes, so they become completely
irrelevant to the anti-tumor response.
It comes down just to the effector CD8s, which you'll
see below, are expanded by both CTLA-4 and in the
combination, they go up even higher than they did with either CTLA-4
alone or PD-1. And if you
look at the effector CD4s, you can see now they have PD-1
because they're activated.
At CTLA-4, in the combination, though, you get even more of the CD4s.
So you go from the P1
situation of expanding mostly the exhausted cells
plus some of the real effector cells and CTLA-4 expanding the
effector cells and some of the CD8
effector cells or some of the CD4s to where you expand just
CD4 effectors and just CD8 effectors, all of them,
and that I think is why you have a much
more potent response. This just shows what I was talking about.
You reduce that complicated three-cell pattern to a two-cell pattern
that just has the classical effector cells in
it. And so one of the things that the CD4
cells that appear when you treat with
CTLA-4 is unusual. This was first noticed by Pam
Sharma again when she did the neoadjuvant trial in
bladder cancer. She told us at MSKCC
of her results, and Jed Walchuck looked at some of the phase three
patients. The patients that had elevated levels of ICOS-positive
CD4s in their blood responded to CTLA-4.
Some of them didn't, but no patient that didn't have those
cells responded to CTLA-4. So it's necessary,
but not sufficient to have these ICOS positive
CD4 cells after CTLA-4
treatment. Well, for the non-immunologists, I need to explain what ICOS
is. It's a member of the CD28, CTLA-4 family, very closely
related to them, also related to the PD-1 family over
here. ICOS has its own ligand. But to an immunologist, when you say
ICOS, they'll say, "Oh, well, ICOS is on TH2 cells
that make type 2 cytokines. ICOS is on follicular T helper
cells that go into the germinal centers in the lymph nodes that help B
cells class switch. Well, what the hell are they doing in tumors because they
wouldn't do anything good?" You don't want type 2 cells trying to do something
against tumors or
class switching. What is that for in the tumor?
But it was at least a pharmacodynamic.
Again, it showed that CTLA-4 had done something. It made these cells.
And
Pam went on to also show that these were required, I'll show you in a moment, for
optimal activity of CTLA-4. But one of the things that we came to
realize with time as we looked is we could not find these cells
in PBMC of untreated patients at the level of a
half percent or so. We could notWe could not find them in
untreated mice. We could not find them in the blood,
in the lymph nodes, in the spleen, anywhere in the bodies of
untreated mice,
or in the lymph nodes or anywhere until they were treated with
anti-CTLA-4
or in knockouts, and I'll come back to that right now.
So we made knockouts to ask whether just the absence of
CTLA-4 might be affecting the functional
differentiation of CD4 cells. And so we made
knockouts, and this compares, this is a
plot
of
the
CyTOF data with wild type heads of the KO,
CTLA-4 knockouts. And what you can see, the wild type in the blue
are those clusters there. Those are the conventional CD4s.
Those red are all cells as you can see over here are not
detectable at baseline
in mice, nor in humans as it turns out.
And really interesting is this continent down here, which is really
off from everybody else,
looking a lot like Australia or something down there.
They drink funny beer, eat kangaroos.
I don't know. Or whatever's
going down down there. But if you look, it's some weird stuff, though, because not
only do you have these P1 positive ICOS positive
CD4s with T-bet, they're elusive by CTLA-4
absence with antibody in the knockout.
But you've got these guys here, including this one, who's really hilarious.
It's got BCL6, GATA3, and ROR gamma C.
Well, what does that mean? Well, it means they're expressing a lot of
so-called dominant transcription factors, fate-determining
transcription factors
that are not thought to have been there.
And so we think one thing that's happened, actually, there's several
explanations for this. One is that you just get enhanced proliferation.
Maybe it's it. We were able to rule that out.
Maybe it was differences in the thymic development.
No, the thymic is perfectly normal in these mice in every
aspect until well after their birth.
And so the only thing that's left is thinking that maybe it's
deregulation of normal phenotypic constraints by CTLA-4.
That if CTLA-4 is always around when
CD4 cells are being primed, and what it does, again, it
inhibits CD28, and so it is going to be
diminishing the strength of the TCR-CD28
signal always below what it would be in its absence.
So when you take CTLA-4 away, you're getting a stronger TCR
signal, CD28 signal than you ever would.
And we think that's supernatural signal, if you will.
And I mean supernatural, like stronger than natural.
I don't mean Halloween spooky. I'm not asking for
Halloween goodies or anything. I'm just saying that these cells are not
normal, and they got really strong signals, so they went down some
pathway that it doesn't normally go down.
I point this out because this is what you'll find in most of the
textbooks about CD4 differentiation.
The cell comes out of the thymus. It's had its TCR rearranged.
It's already had its fate decision made.
It's coupled with either CD4 or CD8, depending on the
MHC restriction of its TCR. And then depending
on what happens when it first sees antigen,
depending on the strength of the signal, the cytokines that are around, all
that sort of stuff, and the signaling molecules that are involved, but
mostly these major transcription factors are thought to just give you
the functional type of T cell. But in fact,
some people have proposed,
a
group at the NIH proposed, Bill Paul and others,
that it's not quite that linear and had all these mixed lines.
There were conditions where cells would express
multiples, and they'd finally sort it out at the end, the individual
types. So we think when CTLA-4 plays a role in that process,
and when you take it away, you end up with a bunch of intermediates that make it to
full differentiation and develop functionally.
We haven't found any of those cells with antibodies yet, but I can tell you if we
isolate those triple positives, for example, from the knockouts
and put them in a tissue culture, they are making all three of those
cytokines that they ought to make of the cell types that you would
expect. Any event, back to ICOS. So
Pam showed in one of our models that where normally we could cure
90% of the mice, if you do the CTLA-4
blockade, if you do that in a mouse that lacks
ICOS, the CTLA-4 or its ligand,
the CTLA-4 blockade doesn't work very well.
So that ICOS pathway has to be intact, both
ICOS and its ligand, for you to get full effect out of
CTLA-4 blockade, which raised the possibility that maybe we could
make the therapy more efficient by giving
an ICOS signal when we're giving CTLA-4.
And so to do that, we went back to that same model and put the ICOS
ligand into the B16 cells that we used as a vaccine
to accompany CTLA-4. This shows ICOS ligand on the
cells and on the
sham Transdu cells here. Anyway, we did the immunotherapy the
normal way. All the
single agent controls are here. But here is CTLA-4
plus the cellular vaccine, just the radiated tumor cells, the same
ones we gave the mouse. This one doesn't have ICOS
ligand. This one has ICOS ligand. So you go
from essentially no antitumor effect to
100% antitumor effect by just adding the ICOS
signal
to this thing. So you can incredibly increase the therapeutic
potentialOf this strategy by making the CD4s a little bit
more
susceptible to
developing down this aberrant pathway, if you will.
And so this is just single cell RNA data from those, and I want to show you here
the two populations of CD4 effectors.
The blue are the ICOS negative, more conventional cells.
The red are the ICOS high. And you can see after the therapy, there's still some
of those conventional ones, but most of the CD4s are these
ICOS high ones. And if you look down here at the
CD8s, again, these are those terminally exhausted cells that go
away. They're completely gone here.
Again, it's only the memory-like
effector cells, the ones that have not undergone that full
differentiation, that still have tied TCF7,
and maybe some tox, but they're high in TCF7 that
remain. So again, you end up with the best CD4s or the
most functional CD8s when you add ICOS for the
CTLA-4 strategy, which suggests something could be done in a clinic
with this, which is something we're working on and have worked on in the past.
Well, there the arrows come. I forgot that this was animated.
I was just making a point.
But one of the
interesting things we found that Naveen Sharba did after doing
single cell RNA and looking at the myeloid cells was incredible change to the
myeloid cells. So this
is what all the
populations looks like in these cells here.
And looking specifically at the myeloid cells, you can see here
these are the more suppressive ones with Arg.
These guys up here, various variety of suppressive genes are up
here. The ones that are more M1-like or whatever are here, the red
ones. And so if you could see after treatment with
anti-CTLA-4 plus Ibac, you have primarily...
Well, those purple ones are gone, as you can see here, but those
red ones are the ones that are still there.
So you've shifted the myeloid cell population somehow to a
suppressive one, to one that can support CD8 activity and
help kill cells. So again, this is a very
powerful activity.
We think these are epigenetic changes, and these look a lot like
cytokine changes. We also
have just parenthetically, Naveen has identified two
markers on those cells that are inhibitory checkpoints of their own, but of
a myeloid population, both of which are involved in that
purple population's ability to
suppress cells that are not found in that red, and we'll be publishing
that pretty soon. So finally, I want to show you some
spatial work that we've done.
Starting, we were looking for tertiary lymphoid structures but didn't
find them. So I'll show you what we did find that was very interesting, and this
work was all done by Mehdi Shaib, a postdoc in the
laboratory with some colleagues.
So this just shows what he found, and I'll come back and do some of the analysis.
But what we found were these tetrads, and what you can see, they're
all CD103, these CC1 type
dendritic cells in the green. And you can see the
CD4 cells are in blue here. White is ICOS.
There's so much ICOS there, it's in the fused membrane that's going
all around these multiples. The CD8 cells are in red here,
and you can see it even looks like there's ICOS down in the CD4
red cells. But these all seem to be held in this network of
a macrophage supporting this
triad. So Mehdi called these
tetrads. And again, we see them with
anti-CTLA-4, but not in the same model when you inject
PD-1. And of course, you see them when you give the combo, even more
of them. But again, this is a CTLA-4 specific
event that doesn't happen with PD-1.
So we looked into that further and looked at what
are the CD4s that are in there. And these are those ICOS high
TH1-like cells that are generated, and those are the ones
that are predominantly inside these tetrads
and not so much outside the tetrads.
And again, there's not so many conventional T cells in the tetrads.
They're mostly outside. And if you look at the...
Well, let's just skip the
DCs for now.
So the CD4s we're finding, it is those ICOS positive
CD4s that are in those structures, and I'll come back to that in a minute.
But first, let's go back to the CD8s.
So again, this is the picture that's emerged on this review article from
Dario Vignali showing the sort of accepted
way
that these cells go. The CD8s, once they get activated, go into two
populations. The first ones have TCF
and tox. One population that has just TCF ends
up being the memory cells
that could quickly reconstitute.
But the effector cells come from these TX precursors that start off
being TCF, little bit of tox, but they end up with tox as they
differentiate and get exhausted.
PD-1 just keeps those going. That's how PD-1 works,
just keeps those going
despite the inhibitory effects
of the
PD-1 molecule. And so
I went backwards one. And so the next thing we did was go to Visium,
where we could go in there zonally and do proteomics and look at RNA,
look at expression. And so what Mehdi did was homed in on the tetrads and then
looked at distances outside for what was going on in
the cells that were associated with it.
And here you can see the tetrad identification in this
slice.And so to show you the data
here, the cluster data.
But if you look at here the data that who's in the clusters,
in the tetrads, the CD8s, they have Granzyme, the high
Granzyme. They're low in Tox. They're high in
TCF, as you can see here.
But if you look at the one that's out, they're really low in TCF.
You'd have to look over here. But they're high in Tox.
So these are the guys that are being primed and given a
function. But they're given it while they still have a lot
of the stem cell factor in them. So that again
is what CTLA-4 is doing
by giving rise of these structures
that produce these highly potent CD8s.
And this is just going back and doing the same thing, looking for the clusters that
many did. When the dendritic cells
lack ICOS ligand, you don't get tetrads.
If you don't have ICOS ligands, and this knockout is just on the DC1s.
The macrophages, every other cell in the body that would normally have ICOS
still has it. They're just missing on only the DC1s, and you
do not get the formation
of these tetrads. So again, this ICOS
interaction is between that high ICOS on the CD4 and the
ICOS ligand on the DC1 that's normally there for the
follicular T helper type cell that's going to come in and help it class switch.
But this is, we think, the CD4, this effector
CD4, by virtue of that very high ICOS on it,
it's been given by the CTLA-4 blockade, then
forms preferentially, sort of pre-empts that
ligand, the ICOS ligand on the dendritic cell that would normally be
seen by the FTH, forms these triads, not in the tetrads, but
just by themselves, primes CD8s then to go out and kill the
tumor. So we think that's what happens.
It just happens, again, with CTLA-4 and not with PD-1.
And this finally is a functional experiment.
You don't need to look at this. But basically, this is a treatment of
a tumor, the B16-BL6 tumor,
which is
very resistant to treatment. And this is just flooding bias
with dendritic cells, either wild type or ICOS ligand.
But anyway, again, CTLA-4 doesn't work very well against this tumor.
If you flood the mouse with
CDC1s from ICOS knockout mice, it doesn't help.
But if you flood them with cells that are ICOS intact, you now
can cure about half of those bias just by putting ICOS on the ligand,
ICOS on the dendritic cells, but ICOS ligand on dendritic cells back in and
enabling these tetrads to form, you can now cure the
bias. So we think, again, that
this is going on. And so Pam teamed up with
us and looked in some of the studies, in some of the bias that she looked at.
In this case, urothelial carcinoma, where there were a lot of tetrads and looked
at mice that had been treated with an anti-CTLA-4 antibody, tremelimumab,
and an anti-PD-1 antibody. And what you can see is there are
these tetrads here, and there are a lot more of them in
responders than there are in non-responders.
But they're also preexisting before the treatment.
There are more of them in the responders than in the non-responders.
But these tetrads are more predictive even
than tertiary lymphoid structures in predicting
responses
in checkpoint blockade. So again, I think I'll sum just
the points that are all made on the left.
You can read them, but I think what's going on again is that CTLA-4, by virtue of
the fact that it generates these supernatural
CD4 ICOS positive effector cells, you
can get rise to these new structures that otherwise don't appear.
That gives you an early way, jumpstarting CD8s, getting them primed
without the necessity for waiting for tertiary lymphoid structure.
We think these things fall apart afterwards, although Mehdi is
discussing a lot of experiments to see what that does.
So very much a work in progress.
If you want to look at this work, it's out in archives and submitted
elsewhere, so you might be able to see it
otherwise. But anyway,
then back. So we think this is a new biology that we can begin to exploit
in humans. And there's evidence for these, obviously, that I showed you at the end
being found in humans as well.
So this same slide, pretty much the
top part of it is the same it's been since 2010.
The only one of the additional
checkpoints that's made it
is LAG-3. In all that time, there's a lot of reasons
for that, that I probably shouldn't go into up here.
But in any event,
we think that there's still a lot more that need to be
investigated that are somewhere in the web of
development. But so far, we're just dealing with
CTLA-4, PD-1, and LAG-3. But all of these others make some
sense. At least some mouse studies have been shown to be checkpoints.
But some new things that have come along in the last period is
additional checkpoints that are only expressed never on tumors, but only
on myeloid cells. VISTA and some of these LILRB
molecules now that are coming along as checkpoint developing.
So I think there's a lot more that can be done as we learn more about the function
of these things, a lot more targets to develop.
But where we've been, to sort of summarize, looking at it as an immunologist
and looking at oncology, was that it always used to be just
taking a whole bunch of patients, treating them with something, and seeing if
a significant fraction of those lived longer, and this is
with really bad diseases, longer than the controls, and calling
that a victory. We know that ipilimumab and PD-1 can both do that.
PD-1 monotherapy moved a median survival over about seven months.
But immunotherapy with
ipi, as I told you, by itself cured about 20%
of melanoma patients, PD-1 about 30 or so.
You put them together and it's over 50.
Optimally, how high can we get?I think that we can keep
improving it with melanoma. We can get that up to close to 100.
That's been shown with neoadjuvant trials.
I think we could, in other kinds of cancers that aren't responding now, by
learning these tricks, putting the combinations together in
a little bit more planned way, or where we take a look at the
microenvironment first, and maybe and then decide what to do.
We could structure these sorts of attacks much better.
But I think our goal should be to cure as many patients as
possible. I tried to mention most of the people as I went through.
I'm sure I missed some, but these are the people, a lot of them over the years that
have helped this work. And I want to give
one last plug for the new institute we've started at MD Anderson, where we're
trying to build the full potential of checkpoint blockade and other
therapies.
And if any of you are interested, we're looking for new faculty and postdocs.
So thank you for your attention.
I'm glad you thought
the questions...
This was the right room, finally, right?
I think we have a question. Go ahead.
Jim, great. In these tetrads, what
would be the role of macrophages?
We're not completely sure yet. We think it's just a scaffolding or something.
We're not sure, but we
see these with the macrophages,
always, these structures forming. We don't see them without.
We haven't been able to identify any specific ligand interactions
yet.
No NK cells either?
Not that I know of. I'm not sure we've looked carefully enough to give you a
complete no.
But so far.
A confident no, I should say.
I'm not an immunologist, so my question might be naive.
That's not a play on words.
I work on
very simple cancers. They're driven by gene fusions, a lot of pediatric cancers
and some adults. And I think at least the people that I
know in the field think of these as being unable to target with
the immune system. The immune system may not see them, in other words.
Do you think there are cancers that the immune system doesn't see and that these
therapies-
Oh, yeah. I think there are a few. I think
we could see more if we worked harder at it by some of the techniques that I'm
talking about. But it may be that in those cases, there could be in
some that had the right MHC, some new peptides that were
generated by the fusions that became targets.
Yeah.
But that would depend on the MHC of the kid, and usually,
you
don't normally, I guess,
type them or go to that much trouble before you do it.
But in any event,
it wouldn't help much anyway, I guess, unless you really wanted to run through the
whole epitope prediction programs and design a vaccine.
But they may be able to recognize fusion proteins
like that.
But
the one reason that I think
there had been a lot of work done in treating pediatric
cancers with checkpoints. I think immunologists' little fear is
all the epigenetic changes that are going on in kids and everything, worried
about
bad things happening. But it's beginning to move into that space
very slowly, and I think you'll see it happening soon.
Yeah. Thank you. Thank you for your work also.
Please join me in thanking Dr. Allison for a tremendous lifetime achievement
award.